obviously we've been focused on a lot of
domestic issues over the past
few days and weeks and months we seem to
be very focused on what's going on in
the united states
that is the time of course that our
adversaries around the world are ready
to pounce
fortunately we're very honored to be
joined now by someone who can help
clear up what's what's going on around
the world the secretary of state
mike pompeo mr secretary thank you so
much for coming on
you bet michael it's great to be with
you so secretary pompeo we have
been kind of inwardly focused i think
over the last few months
and yet as this chinese coronavirus
has caused us all to look inward china
itself is aggressing
around the world they more or less
invaded part of
india just a little while ago killed
indian soldiers
in the south china sea there have been
threats to the philippines malaysia
vietnam
flying over taiwan threatening of japan
it seems that china
is getting aggressive what does it mean
for the ensuing months and years
and what is the united states response
to it
monthly you recounted some of the just
the most recent actions taken by the
chinese communist party
i may have missed it but you left off
attacking the freedom of the people of
hong kong of course
and conducting a campaign of human
rights violations in the western part of
china
to uh ethnic uighurs muslims
turkic muslims that rivals the greatest
human rights violations in all of
recorded history uh so the list your
point is right is wrong from america's
national security perspective the threat
uh president identified when he
campaigned back in 2015 from the chinese
communist party
is very real and so we've begun to take
all the right actions
to to rebalance this relationship in a
way that protects and secures freedom
for the american people you see he's not
first in the administration on trade
but a deeply non-reciprocal set of trade
relationships where the
chinese communist party stole
intellectual property and then turned
around and sold it back to us
dumped it with state-sponsored
enterprises conducted
cyber theft at levels that no other
country
can match the scale of today enormous
set of things that destroy jobs all
across the united states because that
intellectual property
is the grist for a lot of good
jobs for american working people
president trump has taken this on
seriously
i could spend a lot of time talking
about the things that we have done and
intend to do
but the mission set the mission set is
to ensure that the
next century remains a western
democratic freedom-loving century like
this last one and not one dominated by a
model
the general secretary xi jinping the
leader of the chinese communist party
wants it to be well this has been i
think
one of the the brilliant legacies thus
far i hope it will be the legacy
of the trump administration and of your
work to see
clearly the threat posed by china even
when for decades and decades now
politicians of both parties have cheered
on the rise of china and have i think
ignored
a lot of the threats there i know before
the coronavirus took over
the whole country and and all of our
thoughts the administration was touting
this new trade deal with china we were
all very excited about it
then the whole world changed what will
the effect of the the virus
and the lockdown be as we look to the
future of that trade deal
tomoko it's certainly the case this
virus that emanated from
wuhan china killed hundreds of thousands
of people across the world and his droid
destroyed trillions of dollars in wealth
and as the president said
that this scale the destruction that
came as a result of the chinese
communist party hiding and covering up
for this and allowing people to exit
china when they knew
that that had an enormous risk that it
would affect people around the world
and they they should have made a
different set of decisions
uh it makes the it makes the trade deal
look i think the president's word were
uh
it seems much less of a priority for me
today notwithstanding that we hope that
the
first part of the phase one trade deal
is complied with uh we hope there are
places that we can work
with china we want good things for the
chinese people
what we're never going to sacrifice is
american national security and
american economic prosperity so i hope
that the
chinese will decide that their
commitments under the phase one trade
deal
must be complied with we they tell us
that they will uh we'll wait
and see if they come through with their
obligations there that's it reminds me
of
an old line from ronald reagan that he
would quote to uh mikhail gorbachev
trust but verify and i i certainly it
would seem apt for the relationship with
china
you know moving uh michael in my speech
last week michael i
i used that phrase and then described uh
how we should respond to the chinese
communist party as distrust but verify
that's right you know you've got to send
these standards they've broken they've
broken so many prompts michael they've
broken so many promises to
uh to the world they promised they
wouldn't arm the south china sea they
promised the people of hong kong they'd
have their freedom for 50 years
uh the list that they promised the world
health organization that they would fess
up if they had a problem
um this is what happens in authoritarian
regimes
and and you're seeing the effect of that
too i mean i remember early on in the
pandemic there was a study came out of
university of southampton
that said if china had just stopped
lying about the virus
one week earlier it would have reduced
transmission possibly by 66 percent
two weeks earlier 86 percent three weeks
earlier over
90 percent and i think a lot of people
are
are hoping that there will be some
consequence to be paid
or or at least a more just view of our
relationship
moving into the future well i i think
i think that's certainly the case i
think the whole world saw
what michael what you and i know
communist regimes
have a propensity to have the inability
to tell the truth at the most critical
moments
so even today they are denying access to
places that need
access so that we can figure out who
patient zero was how this virus
moved around the world we still we still
got people with
uh this virus and the chinese come to
this day now
call it six and a half months on
from when the chinese communist party
knew the human to human transmission was
possible
it's still the case that they won't
allow a a simple uh inquiry into what
happened how it happened
and most importantly to allow us to
make sure we can get comfort that this
won't happen again
it's not the first virus that has come
from china you uh mr secretary i know
that
over the past four years now we've heard
lots of
fear-mongering about world war iii and
it seems that anything that the united
states does in the realm of foreign
policy
is going to cause world war iii
according to the mainstream media
and democrats and that has not come to
pass yet there does seem to be a real
fear here
as china is aggressing particularly
against another nuclear power
india and as as this lockdown throws the
whole world into chaos
what is the threat level that we could
find ourselves in some sort of armed
conflict
michael this is certainly a serious
business
to your point this risk increased
because for decades and this is not
political both both parties presidents
of both parties
just refused to be straight with china
and this threat level that we find
ourselves under the risk
created to american national security
stems from that weakness
from that consistent cow towing bending
the knee over and over to china
giving them the belief that they could
uh
with the southwest airlines they could
move about the cabin freely uh
and there wouldn't be a response from
the west from
uh freedom-loving peoples and from the
united states and the president has just
simply said enough
we're going to find places we can work
together we're going to distrust but
verify
and when we do that and when we do that
well we'll rebalance this relationship
and we hope
convince the chinese communist party to
behave in a way that's fundamentally
different
than the things they have done that have
taken advantage of america for far too
long
that's right and as as we head into this
election season we hope that uh
china and and other adversaries around
the world
don't take advantage of of that as well
you know we hear
we hear a whole lot about election
interference so uh we will uh
continue to hope and of course cheer on
all the all the excellent work that you
have been doing
mr secretary we've taken up enough of
your time i know that uh
you're a very busy man so thank you so
much for taking the time to come on
we will uh we will trust you and we will
distrust and
verify when it comes to china
michael thank you very much for your
time today so long have a wonderful
weekend
thank you very much
[Music]
you